good morning millennials
welcome back to the toast happy Monday
hope everybody had an amazing weekend
it's Monday we're Rising we're grinding
and speaking of rising and grinding
shout out to my favorite Hustler Jack
Yao shout out to the girl on bed rest
rising and grinding she's Rising she's
grinding she's getting back in bed and
she's doing it all again she's resting
do you like my voice no I don't but
where to what do we owe it I don't know
it's just something I'm trying out
is this a new personality do I have to
come up with a new name for you where's
turdy Lou I miss her turn and lose right
here thank God
I just get like stuck in voices
sometimes I can't get out of it you're
telling me yeah I've been stuck in the
camper for five years she wrote a whole
book about it that's the best way to get
out of it is to put it down on paper
publish it honey
put it in the book give it to the world
just a reminder that my children's book
is available for pre-sale now on Amazon
Barnes Noble Indie bound if you want to
support small bookshops Target Walmart
wherever you shop check it out it's so
much fun I was reading it all weekend I
took it home from the studio because
Harry was like Mama where's my favorite
book oh how you gave birth to Jason
Momoa Harry was like Mama by the way
Claudia I know that we used to roast
Jason Momoa for like seeing actually it
was weird because it was a woman he saw
on TV he wasn't singing Obama let's just
quickly explain the originator of our
mama joke it's probably five years old
yes so Jason Momoa Aquaman Khal Drogo he
used to be married to Lisa Benet and
they they just got divorced recently but
he used to tell the story of how growing
up like he saw her on TV The Cosby Show
yeah and he like pointed at the TV and
said Mama
like and it would be a cute story if he
you know ended up being you know adopted
her son
like Mama like what I just remember
everyone being like Oh how cute I'm like
wait mama yeah no it was really weird
but I'm just what I wanted to say about
Justice for Jason Momo is that is how
Harry says mama like that is the
inflection he says how is your son no I
know but now I'm okay now I'm seeing it
from a mother's point of view what if he
was pointing to the TV and like trying
to get his mom's attention like Mama her
you know oh I could see Harry doing that
like trying to show me the woman he's
gonna marry and saying Mama right like
when he watches my special disgrace
Queen he like points at the TV and he
says mama you want to marry that woman
yeah sure we're so toxic when it comes
to Harry like you know what don't even
care don't even
know one thing about me I'm not caring
no he's he loves it I'm so obsessed I
need to see him like he was so busy all
weekend okay he was he was busy all
weekend but you were really busy this
weekend this was the first weekend that
you weren't here I mean it was the first
weekend that I that I took for myself
you know it's really true I feel like
you've been like hanging around the city
because you just like want to support me
and be there for me yeah you did your
own thing this weekend which I'm happy
for you that you did that but I also
could like feel the separation anxiety
between you and Harry I was feeling it
first time too no like it was tough
but you're back but I had a great
weekend I had a great weekend
but it was tough yeah tell us about your
weekend it looked really great you were
with a bunch of influencers you were
just kind of like on your influencer
grind I know like you know I sometimes
like go to things or just like it's
usually when I hang out with Remy
because Remy's such an influencer that
like I really am reminded like I'm an
influencer you know I just don't
identify as an influencer but like being
with all the influencers like I had the
best time like influencers they really
are so fun so I went to The Hamptons for
the weekend one just because like I
wanted to you know have a nice weekend
but two there was a music festival out
there this weekend that I've actually
never been to but people go to every
year like it always looks fun so I was
like you know maybe I'll go this year
it's Palm Tree Festival it's I think
it's like owned by kygo
um and kygo performed Calvin Harris
performed
um and it was just like a bunch of good
DJs lined up and it was really fun like
me and Ben had the best time mostly I
had a good time because like I was
wearing these pants well yeah your pants
were what made you an influencer because
those were influencing like they didn't
know whether they were influenced an
influencer would wear they were
influencer pants but they were also
um like Rave girl pants you know
yes sort of like dubstep pants yeah you
know like I forget what the dance move
is that like people do like where you
put your One Foot In Front and then back
it's like the mashed potato 100 but when
you say Rave girl I think like EDC no no
no I'm thinking of like what is that
move called it's like the dub or
whatever like no I know it's like it's
the it's literally the mashed potato but
it's now being done at Raves and it has
a new name yeah it's like two-stepping
dubstepping I know exactly what you're
talking about and I feel like other
people do too please just drop a comment
like I was trying to make the joke all
night but I couldn't remember what the
[__] do and when you say Rave girl
Rave girl is like dolls kill yeah yeah
that's not what you were putting off
yeah okay whatever but you know what I'm
talking about I know exactly what you're
talking about
the pants were giving me like this alter
ego and I was just like walking around
like I owned the festival because like I
looked like I did with my pants
um but I had such a good time me and Ben
just like
really we like chilled all weekend it
was kind of rainy which was annoying but
like we stayed at Canoe Place which by
the way you would love like I know you
love like a drivable Cottage Vibe
Cottage Vibe yes I do so this is it was
90 minutes from the city because it was
in West Hampton it was drivable it was
Cottage Vibes they have a spa a pool it
was it's like brand new it's so cute and
they serve Spritz just like added bonus
and it's Strife friendly I you know I
have to assume it I didn't ask but it
was so dog friendly like just in the
energy I assume it's Thrice friendly I
should have brought the I didn't realize
we'd be staying at like a cottage that
had like its own backyard like I really
could have brought Theo and it was like
me and Ben were yesterday we were like
we're both working from home on Monday
like we could just stay one more day but
we honestly didn't want to spend one
more minute away from stride but if he
was there two birds one stone I actually
didn't even know you came home last
night I thought I might be podcasting
remotely with you from the Hamptons
again we could have we could have you've
been so mysterious
I'm so mysterious why you didn't see a
picture of me in my car no but also you
could be in your car like going to
dinner in the Hamptons yeah that's true
it's true it was kind of you know my
first weekend away with the car me and
Ben it was like a 90 minute drive there
90 minute drive back both there and back
we did not stop talking about our car
like all we were like how amazing is
this like we're just like have the
freedom like you know usually we use
Ben's parents car it's like if we had
wanted to extend we would have had to
call and say is that okay and like a
range but no we're so free we just like
we literally were talking the whole
weekend about our freedom so what you're
saying is Freedom Is A Highway
freedom is a hot and you know what this
weekend was kind of just like filled
with Fast Cars and Freedom
damn I mean that is how I feel about
Tesla just like right so I understand I
understand the hype if I hadn't just
gotten a new car like maybe I wouldn't
be able to participate in this
conversation but I totally understand
now it wouldn't be a weekend um away if
I didn't have to unburden myself so I
will go so here you go wait I had more
questions though before you get to the
negative let's focus on the positive
still because you were with fellow
influencers one of my favorite girlies
Juliet Porter you guys know oh yes to
Siesta Key but did you see Alex Earl
because I saw she was I did see Alex
Earl
um
I saw Alex Earl we were like in the same
table area so I went over and said hi
there because I had met her at a rare
Beauty event and we've like dm'd a bunch
um and like you know when you're talking
to someone like you have you know for a
fact that they have no idea who you are
yeah
so she was so polite but like homegirl
had no idea and that's fine she meets a
lot of people but like I think we could
actually just met so many people in the
last year I can't even be mad because
it's like you look different every day
not spinning this into a positive no
totally like I feel like you need to
take into account that like if you met
someone six months no six months and but
a year ago like
you're a different turdy no it's so true
it's so true I wasn't even mad like I
can only imagine how many people like
are up her ass
and I was just another one of them and
how many people feel that way about you
that you don't know who they are but
you're talking to them well
so true perspective
yeah no she was so nice and like there
was um like it was influencer Central
and it was really fun like everyone was
like just really getting LED I was you
know deeply unwell and there was quite a
bit of walking around and I was wearing
these like really big platform sneakers
and when I tell you I my [__] like my
calves are on fire literally two days
later I will never wear big shoes like
that to like a a festival ever again
because I can't feel my legs you live I
was like why I was like why do my legs
hurt so much and I realized I was like
literally wearing ankle weights
um okay but to the unburdened yourselves
ready okay you know a festival is never
like an easy place to go to the bathroom
and there were like you know
bathrooms the line was so long and I was
like I'm sorry no no
so I went into like this parking lot
where like a bunch of people's cars were
parked and it was empty because everyone
was inside the festival this was just a
parking lot so I like went behind the
car I chose like a big one I chose like
a big Sprinter and I just like it was
not a big deal it was easy like right
behind pull my pants down peed all good
and I'm walking towards the front of the
car and the person
um in the driver's seat like knocks and
rolls the windows down
and he was
um fully in the car the car was on I was
peeing right in front of the rear view
mirror the rear view camera
and he was just hysterically laughing I
guess I didn't account for like you know
somebody having hired like a car service
and the driver waiting right I thought
you know it would be all empty cars he
couldn't have been nicer honestly he
didn't even make me feel like weird or
anything he was like good for you you
know the line I was like oh yeah yeah it
honestly he unburdened it for me because
he was so cool and so he didn't mention
anything about you not wiping he didn't
mention anything about my unmentionables
no that's good were you facing him or
like did he see your butt I was my ass
was facing the car
so yeah I was facing face you my ass was
in his face cool cool
yeah no wonder he had it he was fine
with it
you know he got a you know a show free
show from the charity free show from the
30 and you know what
I peed two more times after that and I
kept going back to the same spot
a little bit more discreetly but like I
knew it was a safe space for me did you
bring any like tissue paper no not you
getting like fixated on the fact that I
didn't wipe like what was I trying to do
three times what was I supposed to do
you're gonna get irritation no totally I
was wearing a bodysuit I'm gonna go to
UTI literally thank you
Laura take her I should take my Acora
I'm feeling fine
okay that's good and I'll let you know
if it starts to get any you know burning
or itching
well I'm glad we were able to unburden
yourself I'm glad you had a great
weekend I feel like every time you lean
into the influencer life like you you
love it no I know but like I can't like
dive ahead deep or whatever Ben says
head first went deep into influencer
life because it's honestly it'll suck
you in it will suck you in it's so true
I can't you have to keep your head above
water yeah and then I'm gonna be like
walking around thinking I'm Alex around
like we know I'm not
sure but like I feel like everyone kind
of walks around thinking there Alex are
all and they're like much further off
than you are
so why not true why not oh man I'm like
literally choking sorry I drink
Pellegrino bad big mistake shouldn't
drink carbonation while I podcast you do
it every single day with your Lacroix
but okay um Lacroix is like not
carbonated
I know technically but not as carbonated
as those first few sips of Pellegrino
from a bottle
for my bottle hits different and the
first few sips could take your eyes out
oh they could take your esophagus out
like it's so spicy I know but then it
gets really like stale really fast
that's true
they should work on that
100 the extremes you know what I watched
last night so randomly like Zach just
put a movie on on cable okay but I had
never seen it so I was just taken in by
it the Martian
Matt Damon yeah have you ever seen it no
it was really good okay yeah I haven't
watched something like good in a while I
should really seek out I just really
like enjoyed it and I came in in the
middle so I was still like putting stuff
together and leave like a really small
TV in the living room and like I could
barely hear anything but I really liked
it
well imagine like if you watched it on a
real TV how much you would imagine if I
like saw it in theaters from the
beginning and not with commercials oh
yeah no it was a horrible experience
yeah and I still really enjoyed it at
some point I should have just like
stopped it went to a streaming service
and like found the movie I'm sure it's
on Max or something you see me adapting
to the Rebrand Max
Maximilian I dropped the HBO uh
but I didn't do that and I should have
and now like the movie's kind of ruined
for me that's like when I watch Gone
Girl and I came in in the middle and so
I never had that moment of spoiler alert
like not knowing if she was alive or
dead because I came in and she's in the
car talking to herself about her big
plan
so true by the way
um that also watching like a real movie
for the first time on cable it should
never be done very recently and they got
stuff out too like no it's made for TV
yeah they cut out like transitional
scenes all these things then Ben and I
watched the help I was on E like a month
ago I've seen it a thousand times Ben
has never seen it he thought it was the
most amazing movie I'm like I really
should turn this off and like put it on
but he was like enthralled like I
couldn't touch the clicker no that was
me with the Martian last night it's like
I guess it's better to have watched a
movie on cable with commercials and cuts
than never to have seen it at all it's
so true the jacket is beautiful thank
you so much and now I should go and like
watch it from the beginning but nah nah
I got the gist anyway so it was nice
because
it's been a while since I watched
something good and something I we were
FaceTiming on what night was that
Saturday night yeah after I left the
festival we facetimed yeah and I had
just watched officially the worst piece
of [__] I ever saw in my life and I want
to take back everything negative I've
been talking about TV in general because
nothing was as bad as what I watched on
Saturday night wait I was like so black
out I don't even remember what you're
talking about and just like that season
two episode one oh my God wait do you
not remember this conversation I do not
remember this conversation oh my God you
were cracking up at my table okay
because I watched the first episode but
you didn't finish it I know oh my God
yeah because we had this conversation
but I'll Enlighten you oh my God the
worst show I've ever seen I did not
watch season one but Zach did so he was
like can I watch the new episode so I
was like yeah I was reading anyway so I
was just like not planning on really
watching but I was sucked in by how
terrible it was like I know not even the
show itself the writing like you
everything is so cringe even scenes
between like beloved you know Charlotte
and Harry they don't have their same
like Dynamic it's everything was making
me cringe so
so hardcore also now there's eight main
characters questions yes oh you didn't
see the first season no but I watched
the recap of the first season previously
so Miranda's law professor and Miranda's
not even in law school anymore so I
don't really know why the women would
still be like hanging out with her
um and SEMA actually I like SEMA she's
very fabulous and cute I don't have an
issue with the their storylines or
whatever but like eight people is a lot
to keep up with
yeah well I watched an interview
um Cynthia Nixon did it's clear they're
like over correcting the fact that like
there was not a singular black person on
the original show and it was like so
white and like so now like Miranda not
Miranda what's her name Cynthia was like
you know I loved our show it was like a
perfect show except for and so now
they're like um adding additional
characters to like be more
representative and it's it is a lot of
main characters like honestly I know
this is like gonna be a hot take like I
could live without Charlotte now that I
have like everyone like Charlotte's not
like bringing much except the only thing
she really brings is Harry yeah but even
he was like meh you know they weren't
giving them they weren't giving what
they used to give Carrie is just
insufferable talking about how like you
know she has this Thursday nights with
her first producer and he wants to go
out on Tuesday and like I like what and
she kept having that conversation with
every eight people in the show yeah and
I was just like this is you're 60. if
you want to go out on Tuesday go out on
Tuesday and if you don't don't but like
this isn't like this isn't the Sex in
the City of yore
it's not the Sex in the City of York it
feels like all the characters like all
the actors who are acting with one
another like are meeting for the first
time like there's no familiarity and
there's no you're just so aware that
everyone's acting no and the way that
the lines are delivered like it was
really about the writing like it was so
staged and phony and like it was so bad
like the just the quality of the show
was so bad I was in shock and like the
writing was so like butt clenching I was
clenching my butt yeah
I couldn't believe it
no and it's like for me I've had this
Renaissance in the last few years with
the original show and I love Miranda so
much and I feel like she she I think out
of all them she's the one with the most
um defined personality and I just don't
see this journey that she's on just kind
of like leaving her family behind and
moving to California and following
around Che like I don't Wing Around Che
and Chase like go away yeah I that's
just and then Miranda like maybe I
missed a scene like Miranda confronts
her like why don't you want me around
and then Chase like because I'm on a
diet
but if you could you didn't get there
yet like I guess Miranda was trying to
be touchy with her and like Che went on
a diet for her show or something and so
she was feeling like insecure about her
belly but it's like but why'd you tell
her to leave The Comedy Store
okay I don't really get it but no no
maybe but maybe I missed a scene no but
like that's what I mean like it was just
like these leaps
well yeah and that's the thing it's like
Miranda this is so uncharacteristic of
Miranda like we know Miranda she's a
creature of habit like she you know she
gets the same thing at the Chinese food
place that the person knows her order
like this whole like throwing caution to
the wind and leaving behind like her
very stable family life to like have
some sort of midlife crisis is not
something Miranda would do like if you
know Miranda you know how like
borderline like boring she is like she
just does the same thing all the time
and she likes that yeah but I think
that's why she chose Steve but that's
exactly what a midlife crisis is
I know but like of all the people like
Miranda is not susceptible to a midlife
no but I I okay maybe but I also think
the person who is boring and does the
same thing and always makes the safe
choices like is susceptible to a midlife
crisis
I guess like maybe it's not a midlife
crisis like I don't know I just I don't
I don't I'm not getting midlife crisis
vibes from her except when she was like
in the early scenes when she's like in
L.A and she like loves LA but actually
that reminded me of insects in the city
when they go to L.A Oh I thought she
loved la
no they all ended up hating it I thought
she loved it until that guy chewed his
food and spit it out yeah yeah yeah
she's like oh maybe I could get with
this and she's like no this is all a
facade no that kind of happened in that
episode too she's like doing like the
cryo chamber and everything and she's
like I love this life and then she'd get
some salt water in her eye and she's
like oh that part I did see
yeah
um wait I want to tell you really quick
about
um another show that I watched but
before I do let me just let you know
that today's episode is brought to you
by e-boost so if you're looking for a
nice little shot of energy something to
keep you sustained throughout the day
check out e-boost super fuel it's
non-GMO it's soy free it's vegetarian
and it's gluten-free it has no
artificial flavors colors or sweeteners
it's less than 15 calories per can and
it only has one to two grams of sugar so
if you struggle with everyday energy
because you either you know were up late
working studying
um if you need an energy boost before or
after a workout if you've been traveling
a lot hungover whatever it is e-boost is
a great option you know for me I'm
always looking for things to sustain my
energy because I don't love coffee
um and I really like super fuel because
it's low sugar less than 15 calories per
can and it's formulated with vitamins
minerals antioxidants nootropics not
normally what you'd expect from an
energy drink so when we think energy
drink we think you know like bright
color cans lots of sugar tons of
calories and it gives you that crash
um super fuel from e-boost is very
different it's created with natural
caffeine from green coffee beans and
green tea so whenever we do drink super
fuel we're given a steady dose of
caffeine without the Jitters an e-boost
is so confident that you're going to
love super fuel super fuel that they are
going to give you a four pack for free
all you have to do is pay for shipping
take advantage of this offer today and
go to ebboost.com toast to get your free
four pack of super fuel we keep them in
the studio I have them at my house it's
really a great alternative for people
who live to do more every day who thrive
on the go and always have a new goal on
the horizon so again they're giving away
a four pack for free when you go to
eboost.com toast all you have to do is
pay for shipping
eboost.com toast today's episode is also
brought to you by Kitsch they say that
hair care is the new skincare but there
is one brand that is taken it to the
next level with a cult like following
kitchens created game-changing
Essentials that beauty enthusiasts are
swearing by from satin pillowcases to
time saving towels kids knows that
haircut it doesn't stop in the shower so
whatever your budget whatever your skin
or hair type kitchen believes that you
deserve indulgences at affordable prices
morning noon and night so uh everyone I
feel like knows Kitsch for their satin
pillowcases caps and eye masks if you're
not in the satin game and you like wake
up with A Rat's Nest every single day
use the satin pillowcase use their satin
um eye mask it's so good it leaves your
hair like CR without any like uh
wrinkles in it you know when you get
like a mark from your scrunchie it's
really great they also have heatless
satin curling rollers that everyone on
Tick Tock are obsessed with there's no
heat damage they are original OG
heatless curlers
and you can wake up with like a fresh
bouncy delicious blowout they also have
rice water shampoo bars that could help
with overall hair growth and density and
rosemary scalp oil that helps support
scalp health and hair strength from root
to tip and so much more I love their
Rosemary scalp oil everyone knows them
on like my hair regrowth journey and the
satin pillowcase has really changed my
life Jackie told me for like weeks to
get a satin pillowcase and no not even
weeks months and I didn't listen and now
I finally did and I swear it's so game
changing and kitchen's offering you 30
off your entire order at mykitch.com
toast that's right 30 off anything and
everything at mykitch
m-y-k-i-t-s-c-h.com slash toast one more
time that's mykitch.com
t-o-a-s-t for 30 off your order
okay I started this show last night that
like everyone's obsessed with have you
heard everyone talking about the bear
no it's on Hulu and it's like Jeremy
Allen White who we were just talking
about from Shameless and I think
everyone's just like obsessed with him
so like whatever they were gonna watch
like
whatever that he was going to be in they
were going to watch and oh my God it's
literally so bad I was just like I it's
like 30 minute episodes so the first one
was bad I'm like okay but you know what
like we're setting the scene yeah yeah
the second one was really bad I'm like
Oh we must be missing something yeah
third episode [__] the show like gives
me anxiety everybody's always yelling at
everyone it's about this like sandwich
shop and like there's never any like
it's meant I think to like glamorize
like the he's like this you know James
Beard award-winning Chef who like comes
back to his hometown because his brother
passed away and he takes over his
brother's sandwich shop and he tries to
like make it into you know he's like a
French kitchen like he tried yeah and he
and he was at this like really toxic New
York restaurant that like you know
abused him and like and you know it's
like yeah Chef did you ever see the
movie The Menu no
it reminds me of that it's just like
high culinary experiences oh my God the
show is horrible it's horrible he's like
trying to turn this like ragtag group of
you know like Cooks into like fancy
chefs yes chef pomalia chef and
everyone's just yelling at each other
like no one's listening to him even
though he owns a restaurant like it's
such a bad show like I couldn't believe
how people were talking about the show I
don't get it well it does sound like a
good premise for a show so I understand
how you were roped in
um but no and everything his name in the
show
is Carmine because they're like Italian
you know a family sandwich shop but they
call him carmy
and it just it doesn't roll off the
tongue whenever anyone says it like it
sounds like a fake name carmy
well you know Claudia is a fake name
because it's I know I know and and it's
like it's reminding me when you're
watching television you're not supposed
to be so aware that it's so fake and
that's another that's exactly the
feeling I get with and just like that oh
my God yeah and also what's crazy about
it and just like that is like Carrie
like all throughout Texas city was just
like this Rising writer and you know
Career Girl and it's like and now she
has a podcast
once a week Thursdays and it makes me
feel good it makes me feel like you know
I chose a really great profession so
like that selfishly like is nice but
it's just like all that to just have a
podcast well it's she had a weekly
column and now she has a weekly podcast
but she wrote books
yeah well maybe she'll do she's new to
the podcasting game I do think like them
switching her to beat from being like a
columnist a weekly columnist to a weekly
podcast it's actually a very good way of
bringing the show into like the 21st
century I don't mind that but you're
right she doesn't have that she was like
a driven girly yeah no but also that
would make sense if we were doing like
Sex in the City uh read younger with
young people and like the Carrie
character has a podcast instead of a
column like that makes perfect sense but
like she not to be like ageist or
anything and I'm it's not even about her
age but to like then graduate to a
podcast
yeah I guess after like years it like
Decades of a storied career in writing
yeah I can't write anymore I know but I
can't think and that's a waste but I
can't even think of like a comparable
person in real life who was like a
really big writer who then became like a
digital a podcaster at
like some TV people who were like really
big on TV now like do all digital stuff
which makes sense it's kind of the same
medium but like I don't know it was just
something a little disappointing like
all that for a weekly podcast
that's fair
no and it's like people of weekly
podcasts more often than not have like
other things parts of their job like
whether they're content creators or
bloggers or
stand up and so like podcasting is one
part of their job but it's not their
whole job but it seems like Harry's just
doing the podcast right and is her
podcast successful
right that'll be an interesting like
episode Carrie your numbers are dropping
like do something where's Carrie in the
charts
if she's number one you know and she's
like the biggest
sex in relationship podcast whatever
she's like the call her daddy of
yeah and just like that then okay but
like I just she's been always been so
career focused and it's like this is
where she's at after years of hard work
no you're you're not wrong Jax because
like anyways but as a podcaster I do
feel seen I'm not gonna lie yeah no it's
like everybody wants a podcast and
everyone can have one
so there's room for everyone tourney
it's from everyone
and then other than that I read so much
this weekend me too oh I want you to
update everyone on the rose code and I
want to know your final thoughts the
rose code historical fiction World War
II I loved it I really did and I would
have given it five stars but there was
absolutely no reason it should have been
that long like I like the book was over
like I was reading the book and it was
like over you know everyone was like
settling down and and my Kindle it said
30 minutes left like there's no reason
for that you know there wasn't a final
twist
no
okay
and I really enjoyed it I loved the
epilogue the epilogue gave like a lot of
context for
what parts of the book were real and
then um brought it back to like
something that originally that not
originally that actually happened in
2014 with Kate Middleton so I loved it
it was not my usual choice but that's
what a book club is for I loved it and
the way I felt like
so morally Superior to like everyone in
the past week because like I was just
reading this book and then I was like
looking around at like Ben and like my
friends and being like I'm reading a
book about like World War II and like
I'm kind of like better than you like
the book actually gave me like a like a
real superiority complex now you know
how I feel yeah no and like I was just
like talking to people and if they like
didn't know about my book like I was
just like oh I can't you're so dumb
uncultured swine uncultured twine like
actually and I'm sure like you were the
only influencer at Palm Tree Festival
that was reading about World War II yeah
and it was like nobody wanted to talk
about Bletchley Park you know the famed
secret underground Mission by England to
decode Nazi Morse code like nobody
wanted to talk about that and I was like
well you're not as smart as me it's
disappointing when people don't want to
talk about that
oh yeah because the imitation game is
literally the book but it can be really
isolating when you're in that place when
you're so much smarter than like even
you know your own husband
it was difficult
but that's why you have me
and my book club and your book club
that's literally what it's for yeah oh
an update from last week
um none of my friends listened to the
toast I thought they would all be
texting me clamoring for a ride
it wasn't until two days later that
Rachel who is pregnant like literally
eight months pregnant so we gave her a
pass
she's like oh my God am I the last one
to text I'm like Rachel you're the first
one to text then once I once Rachel
texted me Margo and Abe were like wait
what like what's going on I didn't
listen and now everyone wants a ride
for a second Ben I'm podcasting in here
if you could stop shaking the Tums like
you are in a mariachi band okay
oh okay fine Theo it's raining it's
raining oh okay it's raining okay okay I
didn't stop mine did you stop yours no
no I think it's fine I was just chilling
at them you could just leave it
um
so do you think that it was just a fluke
that Margo and Abe didn't hear that
episode earlier kind of like lying about
how into the toast they are I think
Margaret and Abe don't support me
and you know what now that I've said
that we'll see we'll see what a
frightening car ride you in the driver's
seat two people in the back who you feel
are in supporting you what is turdy
gonna do and oh the only person I have
on my side is Rachel and she's eight
months pregnant she can't really defend
me
yeah that's true well she could defend
you like
emotionally verbally yeah but if it if
it comes to blows it'll make for a very
interesting book club it well what did
you read for you I read free to McFadden
never lie because you recommended it I
didn't find it I I did really like it
not as much as the housemate and I
didn't find it as spooky as you said
like you were like oh and that was the
night that you screamed at Ben yeah I
literally wasn't reading it before bed I
was reading my non-fiction book because
I was like I don't want to read
spookiness before bed but I did not find
it that's oh my God I was like
immediately spooked from the second I
stepped into that house oh no I wasn't
but I it was very twist and turn I did
not predict any of it me neither I like
thought I knew what was gonna happen I
was like [__] I've spoiled the book for
myself yeah I think you're supposed to
think you're supposed to spoiler alert
you're supposed spoiler alert I think
you're supposed to think that her fiance
is EJ because his nipples like wine they
both like wine they both picked the
South African wine they both have
wealthy deceased parents yeah but I was
like there's no way because it was
honestly like so obvious
but I was like I'm just so good now like
I've read so many books I finally you
can't pull one over you thought you were
better than everyone I literally was
gonna text you and be like oh Claudia I
think I spoiled the book for myself no I
know but no it wasn't that unspoiler
alert and then I read the new AR Tory
book she wrote one of our favorite books
every last Secret
which one's that about Nina Nina yeah
yeah so the new book is called a fatal
Affair and I started it last night it
was so good it's more mystery than
Thriller like I didn't feel like it's
like so fast-paced like you know no it's
giving like SVU yeah it's giving SVU
like who done it yeah I'm like five
percent in I started last night yeah it
took me a while to not a while maybe
like 20 it doesn't grip you like Frida
does but
um the story was really paying off and I
really enjoyed it and I did not see it
coming I think next we need to read the
inmate by Frida that's what everyone's
recommending to me
Frida when did where did Frida come from
I have no [__] idea Michelle from my
book club like recommended one free to
book to me and then I started seeing the
book everywhere like everyone was
posting the housemaid and I just fell in
love her books are like really good
length and she's good with the with the
spin like you never know what the what
the thing is gonna be right and there
she's a good writer and they're all on
Kindle unlimited they're all on Kindle
unlimited by the way fatal Affair is on
Kindle unlimited oh yeah yeah I did see
that no and it's like I just feel like
Frida came out of nowhere and all of a
sudden like she's the new it girl she's
I love That Girl in Town there's a guy
on a stream and I swear she writes a
book every six months no she's literally
amazing no she's amazing and the Kindle
unlimited of it all you pay for Kindle
unlimited right yeah it's an amazing
because if you read a lot of Thrillers
and a lot of smut like it's full of you
know on Kindle unlimited most of the
time I have Kindle unliminated and most
of the books I read are never on it but
like since I've been reading a lot of
Thrillers in the last two months like
now it's like you gotta release one from
your shelf you have too many Kindle
unlimited wait what like I download the
book and then you can only have so many
free books on your Kindle so then you
have to release one if you want to
download another one that's never
happened to me
huh maybe you have a better plan
maybe but I think I just did like the
entry plan like I did the trial and then
they started charging me
that's so crazy I've never they've never
said release I don't ever oh I have to
look through what I have on Kindle
unlimited and and give one back but it's
fine because I've already read it not
them acting like the library like
there's infinite digital copies to stop
no it's so true and it's like it's so
stupid it really is but it does make me
think about what I have there and I saw
a book there that I never read that now
I want to read I didn't know I had it so
well I like so far I think Kindle
unlimited is worth the whatever it is
like six bucks a month yeah especially
if your categories are very unlimited
historical fiction is not unlimited no
it's not but you could also only shop
Kindle unlimited books and then not be
surprised if something's not on it yeah
so
um
so what else before we dive in I feel
like this is one of our longest pre-5
show pre Fast Five banters I mean a
Monday is always going to be a lot of
banners especially because we weren't
together and we really didn't catch up
in the catch-up that we did have you
don't remember it's so true so whatever
is a girl to do what's a girl I gotta do
attorneys gonna turn
[Music]
we could talk about how Taylor played
dear John and daylight in Minneapolis
this weekend I know even I felt that
that was deep and she gave like a little
speech before Dear John she did she
basically was like listen I'm
re-releasing this album not because I'm
still mad about the stuff that I wrote
about so don't feel the need to like
defend me to people who you think like
did me wrong like basically being like
just back off John Mayer I think that's
pretty much what she was saying I just
feel like if John Mayer gets a lot of
heat from the album like he's not gonna
take it quietly like he's gonna come
back swinging at all the fans and Taylor
inadvertently too and like she just
doesn't want to go toe-to-toe with John
Mayer
yeah but I mean I think she knew that
Jake Gyllenhaal would just like you know
clam up yeah like he was never gonna
because Jake Gyllenhaal like has a
really
unspoken about and weird pattern of
dating like 19 20 21 year olds so like
he's never gonna come out and defend
himself like he's just gonna let it and
you know what it passed it's over
because everyone's on to John Mayer now
but like if that sort of Title Wave
comes for John Mayer he's coming out
swinging
yeah he's not gonna like take it laying
down and you know what's so interesting
and like something about the swifties
that it's like funny but like I don't
know how I feel about it like whenever
I'm on Tick Tock and I come across a
video from John Mayer's Tick Tock or um
Carly Kloss the comments like there's
not one comment like Carly you look
beautiful like it's literally like
gold eyes like quoting like Taylor Swift
lyrics like and it's so crazy how like
people can't you know people who are
once in Taylor's life and who are not
now like can't move on
well I'm sure they have but like yeah
they have but that's so funny I would
never think like oh Carly you know
struggles with her comments because
they're all about Taylor Swift I'm
surprised she hasn't turned her comments
off like any song that people perceive
to be about Carly the lyrics are just
like they flood her comments that's
really crazy and the swifties need to
get a grip if I know it's like you have
to let people no one's going to want to
get close to Taylor like if we keep
acting this way it's true
so maybe that's like part what she was
saying
yeah but I think she also just doesn't
want to like
she's not putting out this album to get
into a public Feud with John Mayer right
this is 15 years ago or whatever so like
she wants to own her Masters let the
girl own her Masters please don't
embarrass her but people are not going
to be able to accept that
no like I do think Taylor's saying
something like might make an impact but
not it's not going to completely
eradicate the problem no but you know
what it it's good for like me because
then I won't like
dive into the harbor again no no I'm not
gonna like think too hard about it but
what also well 10 minute version which
just gave us like so much more
information that we were just processing
for the first time so so no people are
having the same experience because she
just released what it could have should
have right and would have could have
should have is you know believed to be
about John Mayer so it's like all right
you said you're over it but like you did
just release a song that's about it
okay well not everyone has to make sense
all of the time I agree by the way I
agree there can be some inconsistencies
no one thing about me like I'm gonna
contradict myself
yeah
and that's okay things are fluid
constantly changing life is just
constantly emotion
yeah well we do have a Taylor story so
we'll talk about our swirly then without
further Ado here are the fast five
stories that you need to know
and today's episode is brought to you by
Babel if you have an upcoming summer
trip abroad our go-to travel hack is
Babel whether you're a seasoned traveler
or embarking on your first Adventure
communication or as I like to say
communicado is key to fully experiencing
a new culture and that's where Babel
comes in Babel is the language learning
app that sold more than 10 million
subscriptions and thanks to Babel's
addictively fun and easy bite-sized
language lessons there's still time to
learn a new language before you reach
your destination so if you're traveling
it's just like so much safer it's such a
better experience to like have a grip on
the language before you go but even if
you're not traveling like a really good
thing to challenge your mind like as an
adult who's out of school take a new
language it's like so good if you want
to feel like morally and ethically
superior to other people like I did when
I read my book learn a new language you
can just be like yeah I've taken up
German like I'm just like feeling it
with Babel you only need 10 minutes to
complete a lesson so you can start
navigating and having real life
conversations in as little as three
weeks they're expertly crafted lessons
are built around real life so you'll
learn how to have a practical
conversation about travel relation ships
business and more Babel Has uh 14
different languages that you can choose
from there are so many different ways to
learn with Babel in addition to the
lessons you can get podcasts Games
videos stories even live classes it
comes with a 20-day money-back guarantee
so start your new language learning
Journey with Babel right now you can get
up to 55 off your subscription when you
go to babel.com toast that's
b-a-b-b-e-l.com slash toast for up to 55
off your subscription so take the plunge
you guys Babble it's language for Life
today's episode is also brought to you
by Squarespace Squarespace is everything
to sell anything Squarespace has the
tools that you need to get your business
off the ground including e-commerce
templates inventory management a simple
checkout process and secure payments
whatever you sell Squarespace has
merchandising features to make your
products look their best online so
whatever type of business I don't know
what kind of business you in
um if you're a businesswoman special you
want to invent a Post-It whatever
business a side hustle e-commerce you
want to get into them most likely it'll
require our website and starting a
website from scratch creating one is
literally so hard people literally go to
college for like six years for it
Squarespace is making it so easy you
will get a website that is professional
looking that has all the tools that you
need whether it's e-commerce a Blog and
it'll get done really easily so check
out squarespace.com toast for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch
use the offer code toast to save 10 off
your first purchase of a website or a
domain so whether you want to you know
connect your social media accounts to a
website get traffic overview own your
content that's what I love about con
about Squarespace you own all the
content that you put on the Squarespace
platform because they have a one-click
data portability you get really good
analytics Insight traffic overview you
can connect your social media accounts
you can send out email campaigns share
on social all the stuff so check out
squarespace.com toast for a free trial
and when you're ready to launch use the
offer code toast to save 10 off your
first purchase of a website or a domain
again that's squarespace.com
t-o-a-s-t and that offer code is toast
t-o-a-s-t for 10 off your first purchase
of a website or a domain
thank you Claudia you're welcome our
first story YouTube Star Mr B says he
was invited to join the Titanic
submersible trip and he said no YouTube
Star Mr Beast uh you guys might know him
as do better beast was invited to join
explorers on the Titan submersible But
ultimately turn down the offer to do so
the content creator and philanthropist
wrote on Twitter on Sunday that he was
offered a spot to see the Titanic
wreckage he said he said no kind of
scary that I could have been on it quote
did you hear that Thunder yeah oh my God
it's like thunder feel the Thunder oh
I'm thinking like rain was driving
thunder lightning that's good until
um okay I saw this you know what that
means
what if there's Thunder
it's a chilly day
oh my God it's such a chilly day
especially because Ben's bringing from
home I'm literally ordering all the
ingredients right when this is over
honestly you should order them now have
bang it to work bring chili over because
it's like Harry needs chili by the way
oh I like that idea if Ben's free
tonight he might have a stupid
basketball league but if he's free well
I'll come over for chili that's so nice
that's so nice Okay babe back to Mr
Beast I actually follow weirdly Mr Beast
on Twitter so I saw him tweet this and I
was like that's so crazy but it's not
like that surprising because we were
literally talking last week about how
this company had like had all these like
you know Maritime content creators come
on in the last few years and reach out
to work with them so it's not shocking
it's so scary
um
and I just I'm glad he shared this like
I found it so interesting yeah a lot of
other people and people went to and
those Maritime content readers like have
content from when they went so
everyone's just like coming forward with
their experiences either going or almost
going apparently the father-son duo who
um perished on the submersible the
mother spoke out and said that she was
actually supposed to go with her husband
but that her son really wanted to go
oh oh oh okay because a family member
and said he had spoken out and said he
was like dreading it begging not to go
right but he only did it like to please
his father for Father's Day
okay well you know what the mom probably
knows better yeah and also that he um
he's really good at Rubik's Cubes yes
and he brought one with him he was
practicing because he was trying to
break oh like a world record or
something and I think he wanted to break
it on the sub
oh I can't
oh my God the story is so sad it really
is
and the the mom also said that even
though
um the U.S Navy had heard that the
implosion like the day that the sub went
missing that they didn't tell the
families that
yeah well I saw a bunch of people giving
like um their thoughts on why the Navy
there was like no way to know that this
sound had anything to do with the
missing like this ocean especially in
that like dark deep water like makes
Crazy sounds of course but all through
all those days like they're banging
every 30 minutes is what we hear like
they were giving us something it should
have been brought up they were giving us
all these crumbs and it was like that's
a really big crumb and it's also like
Navy technology not just like ocean like
it's pretty legit and even if it winds
up not being what we think it is like
they were sharing every little fart they
heard in the ocean and you heard
something that you think like very well
could be an implosion that's something
that at least the family should have
known the families yeah yeah yeah but
also but also the public because you
were telling us everything yeah
do you see that Netflix is now adding
Titanic back to the platform starting
July 1st I did and
obviously that's you know an
opportunistic decision but I think
I saw people online like really mad at
Netflix like saying it's so insensitive
and like I don't like really disagree
like I don't oh you don't just you think
it's really insensitive yeah I mean
maybe it's just like a sheer coincidence
like a few times a year a ton of [__]
gets taken on and a ton of shoes taken
off like every month yeah it's it could
be like a complete coincidence and like
it got made into a news story obviously
just because of what happened
um but
let me operate that it's not a
coincidence even though it might be
let's like what are your thoughts if
it's not a coincidence
it's just like my overall thoughts on
this thing it's like yeah everyone's so
invested and people are like making
jokes about it and like some of them are
funny but like at the end of the day
like five people died like innocent
people like who were just you know
trying to have some fun even though we
think it's crazy like they were just
like trying to have fun and they died
and like one of them is a child
so I don't know I I don't know like
because where internet culture gets so
you just like forget when you're like so
deep on the internet that like this is
like a real thing that happened to real
people so like I understand like the
tweets and the memes like I I think some
of them are funny like I do
um I don't know it just like ever every
time I'm talking about this immersible
like after 30 minutes I'm like wait this
is wrong like I can't explain it no I
understand but I also I don't think that
Netflix putting Titanic on the platform
like maybe it's a little opportunistic
and they know that people are really
interested in the Titanic right now but
I don't think it's that offensive one
you know I think if you actually take
the time to watch the movie like you'll
come away from it being like oh [__]
like that is like a mass grave like a
lot of people lost their lives like you
know maybe
it's not just like a joke yeah you know
um because even if they had put you know
a Titanic documentary up a lot of people
are interested in the Titanic right now
like I don't think I don't think that's
right I really don't think that's so bad
compared to some of the other awful
takes I've seen but no if people want to
learn about the Titanic and also like
this thing that all those people
essentially die obsessed with you know
and so it's like
but then also more people are going to
become obsessed
true because it's a magnet
it's a magnet it's trouble but we were
just saying how you and Ben should watch
Titanic you've never seen it and it's
obviously a topic of conversation
Netflix is just catering to that
yeah I guess like honestly when you
explain it that way it's like no it's
not so bad and it's an amazing movie
that they worked so hard on that should
be seen by more people ah you know what
I agree like I don't know how much of
gen Z has seen Titanic they weren't
alive when it came out
no I agree it's a true story well it's
historical fiction Jack and Rose we're
not real but there's a lot of really
true elements and at the end of the day
it's a good take like the lesson that we
learned from the Titanic which was not
learned in this case of the submersible
and literally James Cameron said that
which was that like they rushed um
measures and they cut Corners in order
to you know do this really cool new
thing and that's exactly what happened
with the ship itself oh my God it's so
true
huh
because they wanted to like break the
record for the fastest Crossing because
it was going so well and it was a
moonless night and they hit an iceberg
and if they had been a little slower
they might have seen it if they've been
using they didn't have binoculars on
board
well that's dumb yeah but I I in the
book I read it was like yeah that sounds
dumb but
that was actually coming yeah yeah there
was like got it they had a decent it
wasn't like they just forgot them right
I mean that would be crazy yeah but they
were going really fast and there was
they couldn't see anything
because it was moonless right what's
moon like the moon was behind the clouds
yeah or like if it's like a small Moon
sliver sliver
interesting
but if it's a former unit you can see
more yeah Maritime things
you can see more before turdy goes
overboard
turtle is definitely going overboard
that's for sure
that's for names
so are you ready for our next story no I
like I haven't been able to stop
thinking about anything but the chili
since you brought it up I know it's such
a chilly day and you usually don't get a
chilly day in June in the summer yeah
maybe you want to fire off a text to Ben
or just like place an instacart order
I'll do it after it's still early it's
like not even 10 30. like I can wait
that's true but like I would love an
afternoon chili because I don't want to
you know have it for a late dinner and
just you know heft up plus the heartburn
would be horrible for me but it'll be
worth it for Ben's Chili oh yeah but no
I just can't go to sleep soon there
after or I'll wake up in pain
our next story little nuptial news Jon
Hamm marries his fiancee Anna Osceola
where they filmed the madman finale so
this story is really interesting it's
very mad men filled it is because Jon
Hamm married his girlfriend say mom is
that what I said yeah just give him like
kind of like a British that's how he
pronounces it yeah
um and they got married in Big Sur
California now his now wife Anna was on
an episode of Mad Men that was filmed in
Big Sur California but she was like an
extra
she was a receptionist at that facility
he went to right and her name was
Clementine they met then
he was with a long time partner
nothing I don't know what happened
between them if anything happened that
was filmed in 2015 and then Jon Hamm
didn't split from his partner until a
few years ago
I had no idea that Jon Hamm had a
girlfriend had a fiance I know like if
you would have asked me I either would
have said he's single or he was even
married 100 years like he's done he's
not like um
like very public with his relationships
I feel like he doesn't even have social
media he was previously in a long-term
relationship with actress and
screenwriter Jennifer westfeld from 1997
to 2015 and then 2015 is when they
filmed
well something turdy Lou are you
understanding oh Jennifer westfeld yeah
I know this [__] she um is from one of
my least favorite movies she's from
younger
yes she plays Peter Herman's ex-wife
but it was 2015 they split up and it was
2015 that they filmed
yeah
I thought there was like oh he met her
he went home to his wife and then they
reconnected years later
I believe I feel like she's also from
He's Just Not That Into You
maybe not
um yeah there's definitely something
there's a timeline overlap or something
that's just like so crazy that really an
extra could catch his eye like that
yeah I mean this girly is giving extras
everywhere like hope
it's really beautiful and it's cute that
they got married in the place that they
met I kind of feel like it's a
coincidence
I think it is true I think Big Sur is
like a you know a destination popular
destination people from California it's
definitely a coincidence and actually I
don't know I don't now I don't know wait
the the actual scene that they filmed
together was in Big Sur yeah it's no
it's got to mean something yeah and now
that I realized like it was 2015 that
they met and it was 2015 that he left
Jennifer like it was Big Sir that
brought them together
yeah
no definitely like this is like a shady
like over like time lapse time it's
giving like Don Draper and Megan
yes it is
yeah and Jennifer is Betty
Jennifer is Betty like part of me like
always wanted Betty and Don Draper to
get back together even though like they
were so he was so toxic and like she was
so much happier with like her new man in
her big house like political King like I
loved how it ended for both of them but
like I did ship not how it ended
spoiler alert I think Betty died
what
she had cancer
wait I need to Google this hold on let
me Google it
wait
uh why do I not remember her dying do
you remember having cancer
kind of yeah and then you know the last
two episodes of like any show are just
kind of like a hodgepodge and you don't
so true remember the details you
remember the show as it was and like the
story lines not really the ending so
much like how did it even end for Dawn I
mean that's it's like yeah it's like one
of the like most like debated endings in
TV history right but like even in the
few episodes before the ending like he
was like in a diner
what was he doing
he was struggling he went to rehab
yeah see towards the end it's just like
yeah it's all a blur yeah
well this ending is happy for Jon Hamm
I'm happy for him I'm happy for him too
are you ready those pictures of him in
the gray sweatpants yeah
that's what I think about when I think
about Jon Hamm oh it's not what I think
about I really think about Don Draper
and then my second thought is like Jon
Hamm is actually like a clown and so
unlike Don Draper and not a clown in a
negative way like he's so silly and
unserious goofy actually what I think
about a lot when I think of um Jon Hamm
which is pertinent is his role in 30
Rock and Tina Fey was at the wedding
yeah uh he plays the Reverend no in um
no Kimmy Schmidt oh yeah oh they are
really tight because she did Kimmy
Schmidt too but I think of him as her
neighbor who she becomes obsessed with
and then dates yeah but he like is too
good looking and he doesn't have the he
doesn't live in the real world he
doesn't suffer from The Perils of being
average looking right right that was
such a funny episode yeah
okay let's get into our next story I
want to get your take Taylor Swift
apparently rejected Meghan markle's
invitation to appear on her now canceled
podcast which isn't a crazy story until
you learn what happened actually like
Megan wrote a handwritten personal
letter to Taylor like really like
passionate about how she wanted Taylor
on her show and Taylor's representative
said no like it didn't even get a
response from Taylor yeah so Megan
reportedly penned a personal note to
Taylor asking the pop star to be a guest
on archetypes only to be shut down
Taylor rejected the imitation according
to the Wall Street Journal and didn't
even bother responding herself instead
having a rep decline on her behalf and
what could be seen as a disc to The
Duchess so I have a lot of thoughts on
this my first thought which is actually
not my lasting thought but my initial
thought was like she was dating Joe at
the time and I felt the same like the
entire time that Megan's been like with
Harry Taylor's been with Joe and like if
Joe is a royal like a monarchist right
then maybe he influenced Taylor to like
have negative thoughts about what Megan
and Harry did Jackie I literally thought
the same thing but then I was like okay
that's like kind of pie in the sky but
now that I think about it like when we
know what Megan's show was it's all
about like labels and kind of like
having her guests like break down their
walls and like talk about these things
that people call them and like
that which is like an insecurity for
them
um it's a vulnerable it's a vulnerable
space and I just don't feel like Taylor
is gonna go and bear all on a podcast
and Meghan Markle said that and there
are so few moments in time where Taylor
does interviews she's obviously when
she's like promoting an album so it's
entirely possible that when this request
came in Taylor was Taylor like pretty
much never does press unless it's like
the weeks leading up to an album release
and then she'll do like Zane Lowe and a
bunch of different like GMA but talking
about the music though but like to just
sit and
yourself in such a raw conversation like
I just feel like and she doesn't know
Megan and Meg and I feel like Megan's
show it's not what I would think of as
like really having like genuine Converse
it was very like scripted and it's just
like not where you're gonna go and
really bear your soul like yeah
and I feel like that's what she would
have wanted from Taylor and I agree with
you maybe like Taylor just said no
because she was like not in press mode
but why not respond to the personal
letter yeah no that part feels like a
slight the Morgan ladders
the Morgan ladders went unresponded to
the Markle ladders
I don't know what it means it's also
entirely possible that like she just had
so many requests like this one's not
particularly special like yeah she's a
duchess sure but like I'm sure the P I'm
sure Oprah wants to interview Taylor
like I'm sure she gets the best of the
best
yeah I'm sure that she does and if she
was going to do that sort of interview
it'd be with someone who has like a
more established platform audience of
having really like personal
conversations
that are well received not I'm not gonna
like you know give you my heart and soul
for the first season of your podcast
that you're trying to make fetch happen
so all like random tangent but you
should watch you know Kelly went on
Howard Stern
I saw a clip
I've seen a few Clips you should watch
the whole thing I think they get like
real real deep she also did like a great
interview with Andy she's being like so
open Andy was like I'm so mad about how
much money you have to pay your
ex-husband she's like you're mad
damn Kelly like she's being Savage and
Andy like you know Andy's so like
gossipy he really brought it out like
that Howard Stern interview was like you
know a lot of them I think maybe this
was her first time on Howard Stern show
was like her whole career you know
obviously divorce but also like
Breakaway like talking about everything
more more at a glance whereas Andy
obviously keeps up with pop culture and
he's talking about like what's going on
right now yeah no I've seen she's been
making the rounds and I've seen some
clips but I haven't I haven't dove in
you shouldn't she's so funny and you
know what you know what I love about
Kelly like what I've noticed just from
watching she doesn't I feel like up
until this album release like she hasn't
been she doesn't like do interviews a
lot she's more of an interviewer yeah so
I'm learning a lot about her and like
nobody makes Kelly laugh more than Kelly
like she's always answering questions
and just cackling and I love that like
she makes herself cackle it's so that's
so me that's so me too yeah so she's
like she's literally answering her
question and she's like keeled over like
she can't stop laughing at her own
response that's so funny I love that
about her
um that's really cute I also haven't
listened to the whole album yet so
that's why I'm not like ready to hear
her talk about like I want to experience
it but I've only got to take the first
three songs or something okay like I
just haven't been in A Music Space maybe
tomorrow like while I do my makeup
because I'm coming to the studio Jackson
Studio can't wait are you ready for our
next story yes our next two stories
actually fourth and fifth are both some
book news
fourth being that
what's her face Colleen Hoover what's
her face sorry it says it ends with us
author I'm like no what's her name yeah
Colleen Hoover addresses
sorry Colleen I'm just you know pregnant
no disrespect but it is such a
disrespectful thing to say it's
literally the most disgusting thing you
could say like what's her name
like but tell me like tell me you care
less about something
what's her name I care no I'm not
talking about you I'm saying just like
what's her name she like that whole
thing in general but I just meant like
you know what's her name uh pregnancy
brain sorry Colleen yeah it's fine it's
fine Colleen Hoover addresses
controversy surrounding the casting of
Blake Lively and Justin baldoni so at
book Bonanza Colleen Hoover
um spoke about the upcoming movie
adaptation of it ends with us and
addressed some of the controversy
surrounding the film and actually some
of it what she said was straight facts
so since announcing that Blake and
Justin will play Lillian Ryle in the
film Colleen has faced backlash because
of the significant age discrepancies
between the actors and their characters
Blake is 35 while Lily was 23 and Justin
is 39 while Ryle is 30.
now I'm so bad not so bad but the the
Blake Lively one for sure five months
after their casting Hoover has an
explanation for the age Gap she said
back when I wrote it ends with us the
new adult genre was very popular you
were writing College Age characters
that's what I was contracted to do then
she said I didn't know that
neurosurgeons went to school for 50
years there's not a
20-something-year-old neurosurgeon she
viewed the adaptation as an opportunity
to remedy her error her error she said I
started making this movie I'm like we
need to age them out because I messed up
so that's my fault
so she made the characters age
appropriate to the story
because otherwise people who like never
read the book would be like okay this 29
year old neurosurgeon can't be a
neurosurgeon yeah yeah I feel that and
it's probably I feel that too and she's
not gonna do it twice
no no that I understand but then also
she talks about the clothes but first
she said that she um is so happy with
the cast especially Blake Lively who
she's been obsessed with since Gossip
Girl then she said people are upset
about the outfits and whatnot her advice
is simply to wait until the film hits
theaters she said she loves the
costuming conversations that set photos
from the film have generated and she has
a message for her fans you've seen a
couple of outfits that are completely
out of context I'm not worried about it
okay oh okay because like you know we
only saw her outside and it's very
possible like when she's outside she
just grabbed her [__] and ran because
her husband is crazy like maybe that's
what we were seeing maybe and she said I
I don't remember describing outfits at
all like in the book I don't care what
they have on in my head it's about the
conversation they're having in the story
which I agree about a book but like a
movie a very visual experience and like
outfits maketh characters no when people
describe like what they're wearing or
how they look in a book it goes in one
ear and out the other like they will
tell me that this character they will
tell me that this character is blonde
like a thousand times in my mind she has
red hair like I just I it doesn't stick
with me like visual descriptions are
irrelevant but this is a movie no I know
and that's so funny because when we do
redheads episodes sometimes the
Hollywood treatment like we choose
different hair colors and we're like
wait she was a brunette and you're just
like it doesn't I didn't see it like
that no it doesn't matter like one of my
favorite books is one true loves by
Taylor Jenkins read and like the main
character has a pixie cut and when I
tell you I read that and like threw it
out like it was just it was relevant
because she was like a cute little
blonde girl with like hair down to her
ankles like it literally it doesn't
matter
yeah I agree so that does give me like a
little more hope for the movie
yeah no I mean the first thing makes
sense that doesn't make it better but it
makes sense the second thing is actually
like that's facts like we literally saw
three outfits how many outfits the movie
takes of course over the like I think
like a few years
yeah but also now we're it's a little
bit
confusing on the other end because I
feel like so much of the story is about
like Lily being young and a little naive
and like caught up in this relationship
but if she's 35 like she has years she
should have like be a little more more
yeah
um no that's experience and and you know
what were her other relationships like
in the in the 20 years since Atlas
right because that's true because like
in the book she um
she's like literally for on her own for
the first time and like that makes her
so much more vulnerable and susceptible
to like a powerful rich man who's older
than her who's like saying all the right
things and she's not like you know
looking out and sure so she just runs
away and gets married like it's not
crazy because she's you know with
someone who gets it yeah no that's true
so we'll see how Colleen
figures went out how Colleen sees it and
then our fifth and final story is
brought to you by betterhelp so thank
you better help for sponsoring today's
episode of the toast
sometimes in life we're faced with tough
choices and the path forward isn't
always clear so whether you're dealing
with decisions around your career
relationships or anything else therapy
helps you stay connected to what you
really want while you navigate life so
you can move forward with confidence and
excitement trusting yourself and to make
decisions that align with your values is
like anything the more you practice it
the easier it gets so if you're thinking
of starting therapy why not give better
help a try better help is done entirely
online it's designed to be convenient
flexible and suited to your schedule
just fill out a brief questionnaire and
you'll get matched with a licensed
therapist and you can switch therapists
at any time for no additional charge
that's one of the best things about
betterhelp I feel if you've done
traditional therapy you know that like
the first or second or third person you
meet like might not be the right match
for you but it can get like really
awkward like when you have to tell them
and like leave and it's just like the
waiting room there's a lot of like
awkward social interaction but with
better help it's done entirely online
it's so not a big deal if you want to
switch therapists and you can
communicate with your therapist in
whatever way you're comfortable with so
they offer video chat phone call texting
whatever medium makes you the most
comfortable you can do
so let therapy be your map with better
help there's never a bad time to start
taking charge of your mental health your
mental health is so important can think
of it like brain camp visit
betterhelp.com toast today to get 10 off
your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash toast betterhelp.com
t-o-a-s-t think you better help for
sponsoring today's episode
thank you Claudia our fifth and final
story is a little more author news Ellen
Hildebrand is on her book tour for her
new book and she's sharing what's next
in her career she said she's kind of
like done with writing about Nantucket
yeah she I saw she was on what like GMA
or something yes this morning
oh wow okay and she
um she basically was like I mean
nantucket's really small like I've
literally written about like every place
every corner like I I might have to move
no I know but I just thought since she's
written so many books about a place
that's so small it's like then she could
write so many more because I feel like
there would only be like three or four
books to write but she's literally
written 30. so what's 40. I do love I
mean it's obviously like a
privileged position to be in like to be
able to go out on top and like decide
like I'm done well so she's talks about
like the next step for her or like the
next thing she's gonna do which is
actually really funny because it it's
exactly what we were just talking about
she has a podcast coming out it's called
like beach books and something and they
have like authors on and it's giving
Carrie Bradshaw like wrote all these
books now as a podcast but also what I
found really interesting is that she's
co-authoring a book with her daughter
about two books about like a New England
boarding school which sounds so good
that does sound so good and you know
what's so funny Ellen Hildebrand I feel
like somebody said this it might have
been me but it might have been someone
else
that Ellen Hildebrand is the Nancy Myers
of writing yes oh I didn't say that okay
book suggestions recommendations and
someone was like what's a book that
gives like Nancy Myers Vibes and I was
like Golden Girl by Ellen Hildebrand and
now that I think about it Ellen
Hildebrand is the Nancy Myers of books
it's facts okay like I I resonated with
that so much I actually felt that I said
it
you ever have that feeling we're like
it's so true like I made it up yeah no
totally or it's like it's even nicer
that you thought like maybe you saw it
on Tick Tock and it's just like this
viral thought yeah that we all agree
with
but Nancy Myers works a lot with her
daughter on like projects I feel like we
were just talking about that and Ellen's
doing the same yeah no so that's a
really cool position to be in and I feel
like her dog maybe her daughter went to
a New England boarding school so she can
give her mom like the facts and like
yeah the actual Logistics and then her
mom can write like a great story but
Ellen Hildebrand also writes a lot of um
story set in the Virgin Islands that's
like the other place that she really
frequents a lot yeah like if you um I
read her winter in Paradise series which
I didn't really like but it was three
books all set in like Virgin Gorda oh my
God I love the Virgin Islands it's like
one of my favorite places you should
read the paradise Series yeah I've been
to Virgin Gorda and there's three and
they're really like quick and short and
cute
um but so she's done a lot of like stuff
there too
interesting yeah but I mean she's a
queen she could do whatever she wants
and if she wants to compete with the
redheads like come at me bro with her
just just like you said there's space
for everyone
there's definitely space for Ellen but
literally it's so funny because I was
trying to think at the beginning of the
show of like a writer who then like now
does a podcast and who's like getting
older yeah Ellen Hildebrand except like
she's definitely gonna keep writing and
she should she's and her books aren't
getting worse they're getting better
they're getting better well she just
came out with a new book so she's doing
like a press for what which is why she
was on CBS Morning um it's called like
the five star weekend or something
great I mean her most recent book was um
Hotel
yeah I like that one it was a little
spooky like five keys five Keys yeah
that's what it doesn't remind me of and
before that was Golden Girl which was so
good
Golden Girl I have made everyone in the
book club reading because everyone loves
Ellen Hildebrand but I feel like that
wasn't one of hers that like popped off
so most of them hadn't read it and oh my
God everyone's obsessed with golden girl
and if you
like it's just I just love that book
I love it too and like everything she
does she really never flops even her
books that I'm like aren't my favorite
still I'm recommending it to you the
paradise series totally because I think
you would really like it it was just
what wasn't for me I was gonna say
something I was trying to say it and
before that was like 28 Summers
also good which had everyone in a choke
hold yeah it was very good yeah
and then also her show is her book is
being made into a show so she's like
booked and busy that's what I was saying
is that which one is being made perfect
the perfect couple so she obviously like
is making a lot of money Netflix just
announced the cast it's like Nicole
Kidman Megan Fahey Dakota Fanning like
it's star-sided Ellen's fine no Ellen is
fine and she is busy it's not just a
once a week podcast she's working on no
she's booked and busy yeah and if you
ever want to meet her I think you just
have to go to Nantucket and like walk
the streets for five minutes and she's
there like she's a Nantucket celebrity
yeah that's what snitch and her friends
did yeah oh yeah they met Ellen yeah
but they also took that trip because of
Hotel Nantucket
I also
um when I saw what Ellen Hildebrandt
looked like it's so funny when you read
books and you become familiar with
someone and then like you see what they
look like I would have imagined Ellen
Hildebrand to look like Nancy Myers like
Coastal grandmother but she's like very
sexy have you seen her she's like hot
yeah yeah but she to me she looks like
what you think
like it's all congress with her books
most of the time I'll like read a book
or an author and and then I like see the
author and I'm like oh my God that's not
what I expected no no when when like the
author page comes up I swipe so fast
like I don't want to know what an author
looks like I feel like it really [__]
with me it really does for me it's hard
because when we do redheads I like tag
the authors I have to find their
Instagram and I like to follow every
author that we
have read
pure and then I and then I see the
author
you know and it just like it gets in
your brain and you need to have like a
totally unbiased like clean slate
approach when you're reading a new book
yeah especially in like the smart
category oh yeah knowing you know
someone has kids and they wrote like
it's just I don't want to know that much
I want it like to be anonymous I
completely agree yeah we need to go back
to like pen names
anonymity yeah but I mean if you want to
put it out there
put it in the book
literally
um well those were great stories Jack
thanks yeah they were fun and I love a
little book news plus those are like the
two queens of of the writing world right
now yeah
all right well I believe that's all she
wrote correct that's all we got for you
tomorrow I'll be back in studio which
I'm really excited about
Wednesday we have gbt gbt is making her
return Thursday you're in studio with me
again
and then Friday remote because it's
Friday it's like a summer Friday and
it's like the biggest holiday weekend of
all because it's like five days oh yeah
yeah because we won't be back on the
podcast till Wednesday because of July
4th yeah because July 4th falls on a
Tuesday so
you can really extend oh you're going
away yeah fun but not till Sunday oh
cool that's what you get when you have a
really long weekend that's what you get
when you let your heart win thank you
guys so much for listening to the toast
on Monday Morning Show we told the
faster stories that you need to know
every Monday through Friday on YouTube
so if you're watching this on YouTube
please subscribing give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as
practice and we're podcasting events on
Spotify
love ya bye